what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
delving into the latest unexpected
developments in the boku no hero story
including the fate of the bunny queen
miracle the apparent conclusion of the
fight against the high-end nomal and the
truth about shi gerecke's current
condition it is my opinion that
horikoshi is trying to fool all of us
right now he is trying to psych us out
and lower our guard in preparation for a
massive an earth-shattering twist that
is about to occur in the next few
chapters so do not lower your guard
because this arc has not yet reached its
climax and we need to talk about it all
right now
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
on this channel you want us to keep it
going please leave a like to let me know
it really does help and if you happen to
be new to anime roar please don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications a huge
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible as you might know YouTube ad
rates have been absolutely plummeting as
a result of the global crisis so your
support means more than ever thank you
so much I'll talk more about patreon at
the end of the video but first please be
advised that this video will be
containing boku no hero manga spoilers
we are talking about the latest events
in the story up to this point so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned chapter 269 of the manga starts
off in the aftermath of endeavours
attempt to rescue miracle from the
clutches of the super boo nomu and
thankfully miracle is totally fine guys
it's just a surface wound nothing to see
here
it's clearly just a scratch I wasn't
freaking out at all when I was reading
this not at all seriously though when I
saw the leaks of the panel showing the
extent of miracles injuries I froze I
honestly thought that horikoshi was
about to kill the best girl in the
entire series and I was about to lose it
but then once the full chapter came out
we saw that endeavour was able to use
his quirk to cauterize miracles wound
which of course is going to stop the
bleeding and hopefully keep her alive
long enough to get some advanced medical
help
please hoodie cause she tell you what
let's just give like eight shots of
trigger to recovery girl and let's make
this happen
you said it yourself you love drawing
miracles so be a friend and let's make
miracle safe again now you might think
that I'm just memeing here oh he was
upset about a fictional anime character
but no I genuinely love Mirko as a
character and I do not want anything to
happen to her I even made a video
recently talking about why I proudly
symp miracle and that video was too hot
for YouTube
it got demonetised and I didn't even get
a chance to appeal it I can't even show
the thumbnail in this video but if you
want to see it I will link it down in
the description and independent alright
back to the story as he heals medicos
wounds and ever thinks about how much
miracle must have gone through just in
the past five minutes she was facing off
against multiple high and no mo at once
and endeavour clearly has a ton of
respect for me to go as a hero which he
damn well should me to KO is an absolute
mad lass and never recalls how Motoko
had also helped him back in Kyushu and
he begs her not to die but just as
endeavour finishes helping miracle and
he better have finished bro I'm not even
kidding he better have done what he
needed to do because in the very next
moment the female Nomo appears and
lunges at it never she instantly
identifies endeavour as the number one
pro hero and she decides that fighting
against him should be more fun than her
previous fights meanwhile the other
heroes are facing off against the
remaining normal high zihua is erasing
the no moose quirks while crossed
present mike and some guy called the
vision hero are trying to take the
monsters down even as they are fighting
the nomal whose bodies still haven't
fully woken up and who may still get
stronger if they are not destroyed
immediately crust warns everyone that
stopping shigaraki must be their top
priority Shigure Aki is located in one
of those tubes or capsules at the other
end of the lab and he is not just your
average villain anymore after you
giucose procedure he has become
something different something more than
just a villain and
heroes must prevent his awakening at all
costs this is also something that
miracle realized as soon as she got
close to she Guara his tube her senses
had immediately warned her that the new
shigaraki is dangerous beyond words as I
said I saw eyes doing his best to erase
the quirks of the normal and he knows
that hero reinforcements will arrive
very soon but he also knows that the
female normal managed to escape the
effects of his erasure and this nomu is
probably already facing off against
endeavor and of course as we know the
female nomu did indeed just attack
endeavor however they're still like
three other nomu that need to be
pacified in this section of the lab so I
so I can't afford to go after the female
normal even though reinforcements are
only seconds away those few seconds
could prove to be very deadly for the
heroes if they make even a single
mistake over in the other section of the
lab who Chico is about to reach his
breaking point he absolutely did not
want to awaken shigaraki prematurely
because that could ruin everything and
destroy all the work that he and
all-4-one had put in for these last few
years but if he doesn't awaken shigaraki
now it is likely that the heroes will
capture or kill him while he's still
helpless and motionless inside his tube
Fujiko decides that he must act now but
just as he is about to press the button
to awaken shigaraki present Mike uses
his quirk to destroy she gerak his tube
and shigaraki collapses to the ground
along with all the shattered glass and
liquids from the tube itself before Waja
Co can have another freakout present
Mike shows up and gives him a good old
DJ punch right to the face but this was
more than just a punch this punch was
driven by all the trauma that Yugi co
had put present Mike and his friends
through it was driven by what happened
to Oboro present Mike's and Iowa's
childhood friend whose corpse was
secretly used by Yugi code to create the
highly intelligent normal known as guru
giddy although I still believe that
Oboro wasn't a corpse when you Chico
turned him into a gnome
I believe that Oboro was still alive and
that is part of the reason why kudo
kitty
such a unique normal in that moment the
biggest NPC of the current Hiro group
that vision hero guy approaches
shigaraki he places his hand on she got
at his chest and he proclaims that
shigaraki is not breathing the reason
why I call this vision hero guy on NPC
is because he is the hero that we know
the least about and yet he's the one who
approaches shigaraki I'm getting the
feeling that this guy is not long for
this world but more on that later the
heroes are surprised that she Guara he
isn't breathing and that apparently even
his heartbeat has stopped
Fujiko explains that in order to make
the stabilization run smoother he had
placed shigaraki into a state of
suspended animation
the tube the container was keeping him
alive
during this process and now that the
container has been destroyed before she
got aki could awaken he is apparently
lifeless dead Fujiko despairs about the
current situation he has done so much
for shigaraki sake and yet now it seems
that it was all for nothing all of his
best laid plans are collapsing and
shigaraki fujiko's masterpiece and the
culmination of all of his and all for
one's work is no more in the very next
moment the hero reinforcements arrive
including space hero 13 ryo q Gran
Torino and many others all these many
heroes attack the remaining high ends
and it appears as if it's all over it
seems that thanks to the UQ and a bunch
of other heroes and never was able to
destroy the female normal and so all the
plans that the villains made appear to
be falling apart the last page of the
chapter shows Shigeru keys seemingly
lifeless face and then it shows a
glimpse of Tartarus prisoned and all for
one the ending of the chapters strongly
implies that all for once plans have
been thwarted that now finally it's all
over the heroes have won shigaraki is
dead the villains have lost but sorry ho
Takashi I have not buying it
I am NOT buying this at all there is no
way that this is how this art will
actually end and I predicted both
shigaraki
the female normal are still alive the
other Nomo might get killed but I think
that the female Nomo is special and I am
certain that after all this build-up
shigaraki is not dead he might be
lifeless now but he is about to awaken
either he will awaken on his own or you
Chico will find a way to awaken him but
she gerak he will definitely rise again
and we are about to see the full extent
of his new power we are about to find
out why she kuraki is no longer
considered just an ordinary villain but
something far more terrifying and far
more dangerous as good as things might
look for the heroes right now this
arrival of the hero reinforcements could
mean that we are about to see a lot more
hero casualties because when she kuraki
does awaken all of these heroes become
potential targets as I said the vision
hero guy will probably be first and then
after him who knows how many other
heroes could fall victim to shigaraki
Zanu power I've said it a hundred times
but I just want them to get miracle out
of there and rescue her first and then
she got a key can awaken and do his
thing sorry other heroes you're all cool
and stuff but we must protect miracle
everyone else is on their own as far as
I'm concerned and best of luck to all of
you but overall I really have to give it
to horikoshi this entire arc has been so
intense and so suspenseful and it is
full of twists and turns and
misdirection this apparent conclusion to
the battle of jakku hospital is
definitely a misdirection
horikoshi is psyching us out and there
is absolutely no way that she gerak II
won't wake up and ruin the heroes day I
am willing to bet on this and if I'm
wrong I promise I will make an entire
video shamelessly simple for miracle oh
wait anyway let me know what you guys
think do you agree with me that this is
a psych-out and that shigaraki will
indeed wake up if so how strong do you
think she Guara he will actually be
finally which heroes do you think could
actually be killed by shigaraki now that
so many of them have entered the lab
aside from the vision hero of course
because he's definitely toast and by the
way if anyone in the comments says that
miracle will die I will immediately
block you on Twitter and delete
tik-tok account because that is not cool
fam not cool if you enjoy this video and
you want to see more please leave a like
to let me know it really does help and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking that
bell and selecting the option that says
all otherwise YouTube will bury our
videos and you won't see them it's just
the way it works you could also hit me
up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar I want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime uproar patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thank you to baby ray and a
friend a disciples of Lord Twigg o
himself and I can't forget all are the
one-tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including in grata alone
Adam the world stealers the school bus
Tyson Quintino acquired respect Pat a
heffa Jonathan king deci d and brandon
Ovilus finally big thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings eldress Anatole
Kazansky unhealth
team Sparky 65 of Rohan Kapoor cricket
XP Ted no Ted
Salter Joe Stanton very Gucci Alisha
actor animal as 69 jessica calif on he
no kami and water
Bonnie parks zou d'art 12 rothwyn de Ora
Emperor otaku JCCC waka the coach and
Tendo if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value for you
please consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar gives you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]